because she's one of the more a
beautiful soul that I've ever met
fiercely intelligent unbelievably
compassionate and has a perspective on
global politics that we desperately need
she's heroic and if you haven't read a
problem from Hell read the book she's
hurting she's a hurting hurting person
right now and it's so pained and if you
go through the whole interview which
very few people I've even read the
transcript and the report are not even
letting her know she was being recorded
and it was just a very horrible perfect
storm
a monstrous course of events no pun
intended but for me as I told her right
now I actually this is to say the advice
I gave her last night I said she's
beating herself up and I've been there
before where something comes out of your
mouth that you're like God could I take
that back
is number one her what she did is
exactly what I've done in those
circumstances you just beat yourself up
so much that you damaged your spirit and
you become shy and cautious and I try to
encourage all my friends to live as
courageously as possible so I told her
to protect your core but don't just
protect your core the spirit of who you
are which is a good soul that it has a
purpose and a mission in this in the
short time she's gonna be on this planet
but I said to assert your core just go
out there and continue to be
authentically yourself the truth of who
you are will always emerge and she was a
Pulitzer Prize winning world changing
author before this crisis and she will
emerge from this as a Pulitzer Prize
winning a courageous author a world
changer after this and and as long as
she doesn't let this crisis affect the
core of who she is
yeah pragmatic politics yeah she was
right booth you don't want to do damage
to your candidate and Barack to his
credit I mean this is again yeah I
support Barack I know I'm actually more
of a personal level I know he's a great
guy but seeing the way he's treated her
during this crisis really touched me she
basically said that look he felt so bad
about this didn't want to do it and then
cut her loose and then his continuing to
call her and check in on her I mean the
guys running a national campaign he's
checking on our friend he's just really
genuinely concerned how you doing today
cuz I know she's wept over this she's
paying over this and to hear that Obama
is in the middle of a campaign and I
know how insane I get over the campaign
hard for me to call my mom every day but
to hear that the Barack Obama is
checking on his dear friend because he
knows that her career she's got this
phenomenal book it's already on the
bestseller list in some places that is
giving way overshadowed she's telling me
last night that she was even thinking
about canceling Colbert so which is one
of the best book selling places to go
but you know she's so worried about
having to she's so worried about having
to go on and perpetuate a story that
could hurt the campaign so so here is
this woman that Obama is rightfully
concerned about who made a mistake who
know she says something really wrong she
knows she stuck her foot on her mouth
she by the way she respects Hillary
Clinton that's the irony of it all and
she's on the record way before saying
positive things about her and her
husband but this one reporter was able
to twist and push and prod until this
came out and by the way she had done she
flown an all nighter she had done nine
interviews she was tired as all heck and
she said this so it was a good window
for me to see the her kind of character
and see the character of Obama and
she'll get shook it over this